nous voilà dans l'intimité des archives
départementales du loiret à orléans sous
une faible lumière sur cinq étages un
paysage de papier semble attendre son
lecteur installé en 1913 dans cette
chapelle désaffectée mais aussi sur un
deuxième site à la cité coligny notre
mémoire départementale s'étale sur plus
de 30 kilomètres linéaires
amandine conservateur du patrimoine
directrice adjointe nous guide dans ce
dédale des archives parfois vieille de
douze sièges les archives
départementales c'est une création de la
révolution française c'est une loi du 5
brumaire an 5 qui a permis
l'instauration dans chaque chef-lieu de
département d'un service d'archivés
reliés à la préfecture qui devait
récupérer tous les documents d'ancien
régime dont on pouvait encore avoir
besoin des anciennes juridiction des
nobles qui avait émigré des institutions
religieuses qui ont été fermés à la
révolution
les premières archives en france remonte
au 9e siècle
installé dans une tour du louvre elle
permettait aux nobles de faire
reconnaître leurs droits et acquis la
révolution française en reprend le
principe pour protéger les droits de
tous citoyens
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a à
la fois des documents administratifs
documents qui sont produits par des
courbes des juridictions des écoles des
hôpitaux des notaires vraiment un panel
très large et en même temps une collecte
des documents privés des documents qui
sont produits par vous et moi par des
associations des entreprises et qui font
aussi la richesse de l'histoire et du
patrimoine du loiret chaque jour sont
collectées auprès d'administrations
d'établissements publics ou privés des
documents utiles aux droits de citoyen
mais aussi à la compréhension de notre
histoire claire secrétaire de
documentation travaille aujourd'hui sur
des archives familiales sa mission
étudier l'importance de ces documents
puis créer un répertoire à destination
des lecteurs sa faune très riche puisque
ça couvre la période de la première
guerre mondiale où louis de rennes et
soldats il a fait toute la guerre et
après ça couvre la période la deuxième
guerre mondiale avec l'occupation et lui
il avait un peu une vocation de tout
conserver et il avait dans la fin il
avait un esprit journalistique
donc il écrivait beaucoup et des
cimaises sur l'ensemble des archives
récolté seuls 10% sont sauvegardées et
déjà la conservation est difficile
espacez conditions de stockage
manipulation par les lecteurs les
documents souffre alors la sauvegarde
numérique devient indispensable
par exemple actuellement sur une
campagne de numérisation de l'état civil
et des registres paroissiaux et là ça
permet de ne plus faire consulter ces
documents
historique originaux qu'il faut
conserver le plus longtemps possible et
de faire quand même partagé les
informations par le biais d'internet
la numérisation l'intérêt de
l'exposition sur internet des documents
c'est que là où on pouvait toucher 1000
1500 personnes physiques qui venait
chaque année consulter les documents sur
internet on passe plutôt à des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui peuvent
être dans le monde entier qui peuvent se
connecter à n'importe quelle heure du
jour et de la nuit et qui peuvent
consulter ces documents et après on
faire des usages à très intéressant
intéressant car les archives permettent
des recherches dont de nombreuses
thématiques petites ou grandes histoires
généalogie architecture patrimoine
chacun vient ici en salle de lecture
comme un chercheur
tant qu'il y aura du papier et tant
qu'il y'aura l'histoire à faire il y
aura des chercheurs on a un grand
patrimoine en france on a la chance
d'avoir une histoire plus récent mer et
on a la chance d'avoir pu conserver les
documents pour faire l'histoire
ce qui permet aussi d'avoir dans nos
salles encore beaucoup de monde qui
vient s'intéresser à ces questions
chaque année 1500 lecteurs consultent
sur place gratuitement plus de 30 mille
documents professionnels ou amateurs
chacun vient ici chercher des éléments
de réponse pour éclairer son histoire où
notre histoire